- [Mark] We're rolling, we're on.
- Let's do it.
- [Mark] We're on with Garyvee.
- Thank you.
- This is incredible.
This is really awesome
for me to be here today.
I got my man, Jim McDee who's been with me
from the very beginning.
He's kind of seen all the stuff
I have grow over the years.
- He was a bouncer driving
a beat up Chrysler 300
when I met him.
- I love it.
- Pretty much.
- Where was that?
- Well you guys were living
in Davis at the time.
- [Gary] Davis?
- California.
- That was back in 2005,
2006 somewhere in there.
- 2005.
- [Garyvee] You read Crush It.
- Read a book called Crush It.
- How'd you'd you get, do you know?
- My dad was into it.
My dad's a huge mentor
to me much like your dad
was to you.
And, he's the one who
kinda told me about it.
I was like, "Dad, I'm
not really into reading."
I hate to read.
- [Gary] Yeah me too.
- It's a huge challenge for me.
So I get the audio book, and it's you--
- Which was even better.
- [Mark] Narrating it.
And, I go, "Oh my God, this
guy's annoying as hell.
- That's right, yep.
- [Mark] This guy's got a lot of fire.
But, once I started listening to it more--
- You were able to get
through that, right?
- [Mark] I was able to get
through that just fine.
- Cause some people don't
- Well the reason I'm
able to get through it
is because I realized
very quickly into the book
that that's who you are.
So when somebody's trying to
be amplified or over the top--
- [Garyvee] Sure if
they're forcing it yet.
- For bullshit reasons,
then I'm like fuck this guy.
- I get it.
I'll take anybody in their pure for.
Anybody.
- [Mark] I enjoyed it a lot.
Some the of the general
principles you shared
in that book helped me
and my wife tremendously.
- [Jim] Experience when my
best friend passed away.
He was a colonel at the Pentagon.
He had a ton of people at his funeral.
Everybody was saying these
fantastic things about him.
Like I knew he was a great
guy, but there were people
saying that he changed
the course of their lives.
I'm like, "Have I done that for anybody?
- [Garyvee] Yeah I get it.
- [Jim] Like how many
pallbearers can I pull together?
- I get it.
- [Mark] Jordan has told me that fitness
has changed your life, and
it's put a lot of money
in your bank account.
- Is that true?
(laughing)
- [Jordan] I did not say that.
- He actually said almost
kind of the exact opposite.
- You know it's
interesting a lot of people
ask me about getting into better shape
over the last couple of years.
You know it's so funny
it's the same way I think
about business and life.
It's unbelievable to me that
I don't necessarily feel
so much better.
Like we keep, you know,
and you guys probably are
more grounded than this.
It's been fun to realize
you keep finding new spots.
Like oh shit, now I've
realized my shoulder.
This is literally last week.
You don't know it.
I didn't know at three,
you know, I knew that I was
not doing anything that was smart
with my eating or physical
fitness three years ago
which is why I started doing it.
- [Mark] You kind of
stuffed it under the table.
- You know I did it because I knew
I wasn't doing the right behavior.
But, to say I feel so
different, there's a couple
little things.
Like I know when I carry Xander
down the street one armed
for four blocks and don't
get tired after three steps.
That makes sense.
Grabbing my luggage.
But, energy-wise I
don't feel any different
because I have so much natural energy.
- [Mark] You had a lot of energy anyway.
- But, even though I don't feel
these remarkable short term results,
I know how this plays out.
I know what my life looks like at 74.
You know you gotta
understand supply and demand.
- [Jordan] The pond got bigger.
- [Mark] What we've seen in
our community is people's lifts
getting a lot better.
So I'm watching him, I watching this guy,
I'm watching that guy,
and because the lifts
have gotten so much bigger,
now what a 700 pound
deadlift used to be kind of the norm.
- The norm is like exceptional.
- Well now we're seeing,
yeah in power lifting.
Now we're seeing 800, 900,
1,000 pound deadlifts.
What do you think Instagram
has done for business?
Has it done something
similar where they're seeing
somebody like you, and it's
driving them to push themselves?
- That's a really good observation.
So I think what that does
when you have more awareness
of everything, what it
does is exposes people.
So I don't think there's
a general answer of that.
Winners say, "Fuck 750, I'm going 760."
A lot of people go the other way
and get discouraged and bow out.
It's the way I think about rich kids.
I've now, I've succumb.
Something I tried, I
don't know how I thought
I was gonna fix this.
But, like I'm aware that my children
are gonna grow up extremely well off.
And, they're gonna do one or two things
once they realize what I'm up to.
They're gonna look at
that, and they're gonna say
what I did with my dad
which from where we were
seemed like a big accomplishment,
"I'm gonna climb that mountain."
I mean I used to tell my dad like,
"I'm gonna do so much more than you
"that you're gonna feel
that it's disrespectful
"to even put up our names."
I was so competitive with my own dad.
I'm like, "You're not
even gonna say my name
"because it's gonna be disrespectful
"to compare the two of us."
And, he would get mad too.
We were competitive.
You know I've been watching,
now I have fancy friends,
well-off friends, third
generation wealth friends,
and a lot of kids go
completely the other way.
They're gonna be like, "Well
I'm not gonna climb that.
"And, actually I kinda
feel guilty that I fly
"in private jets and have a Hamptons home.
"So what I'm actually
gonna do is I'm gonna take
"mommy and daddy's money and give it away.
"I'm gonna be a nonprofit,
or I'm gonna go build homes."
And, by the way, I'm
comfortable with whatever Misha
and Xander decide to do.
I genuinely am.
But, that's what happens when
you get exposed to big things.
You either decide, and the
reason you see 800 and more now
is a small percentage of the great winners
put in the triple work
because they're aware
and push it forward.
One of the biggest reasons
athletes are better
in today's world is
Magic Johnson didn't know
that Larry Bird was
taking 5,000 free throws.
- Yeah.
- They just found each other in college.
And like, "Damn."
- Greatest rivalry of all time.
- Now, everybody's, you
know, when you're six,
seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12 years old,
they're grading kids at such a young.
You know where you sit.
And, it's pushing you harder
if you're really that star.
And, so maybe Larry Bird
would've taken 3,000 shots
if he knew Magic was taking 1,200.
- [Mark] How old are your kids?
- Seven and four.
- [Mark] What do you think
is the most important
thing to do with them
in terms of, you know
a parent is gonna have to be the one
that has to guide their kid.
You're gonna have to make your kid
do things that they don't
wanna do such as like
eat vegetables or finish their dinner.
Just not eat too much
sugar and so on, right?
- Or not.
I think one of the great
debates that I play with now
is what is established,
cliche eat your vegetables,
and what is actually the
value of that in reality?
Truth is the far majority of people I know
probably didn't eat their vegetables.
Definitely anybody who's
41, ate way too much sugar
and drank soda, I mean I drank
soda everyday of my life.
To me, the things I think
most about are number one,
two, three, and four is
to build self-esteem.
So my belief is that
self-esteem is the only drug
that combats the world.
I genuinely believe that.
- [Mark] That's powerful.
- In parallel, it's imperative
that you don't build
fake self-esteem.
Self-esteem can't be
manufactured through rewarding
non-rewarding events.
- [Jim] Like participation trophies.
- Correct.
You can't come in eight
place in the race in school
and then get prized
for that because that's
just not real life.
However, Xander for example
this weekend when Max
got hurt, his nephew,
stopped what he was doing
and came over and showed amazing empathy
for a four year old.
That has become now the
thing I've talked to him
about for two days.
That's he's incredible, that
you have such a great heart.
To me, you triple down.
This is by the way this is me being
a byproduct of being what
I think perfectly parented.
This is what my mom did.
My mom over exaggerated my
natural goodness as a person
to make me believe it was
the most important thing.
And, she never gave me
third place trophies.
And, when I lost, I lost.
And, she made me realize there
were repercussions in life.
So when I got bad grades
even though she knew
I was gonna be very special,
I was literally punished.
It was like clockwork.
You know how like the sun
and the moon do their thing?
From fifth grade to senior of high school,
I was punished every single mid October,
that's the first report
card to late December,
early March and the end of the year.
- [Mark] What age?
- Literally from fifth grade,
for seven to eight years
consistently I was grounded.
- [Woman] I know, we're
in the middle of that.
- You know I think it's interesting.
I think that subconsciously I knew
that it wasn't the most
important thing in the world,
but I do like that she
punished me and didn't let me
completely disrespect the system.
But, she never let it hurt my confidence.
She played it very smart.
And, there is something
interesting my parents did.
At 14 they said, "Look
tough guy, you're not gonna
"be a student, it means you're gonna work.
"And, so that means you're
gonna start working now."
So I do think one of the
great things my parents did,
and I think a lot of parents
should think about this
is if you don't have a student,
even if they're an artist
and wanna sing and paint,
you need to figure out
how to establish massive work ethic.
Because the only thing that's controllable
for somebody who's gonna
be on themselves in life
is their work ethic.
Their talent, you can get it better.
Right you can lift more, you
can get better at things,
but like my calves and ass
aren't naturally the same
as everybody else.
And, there's people
who are naturally like,
I don't like my chest is never gonna be
as big as I necessarily
want it 'casue there's
certain things that are, right?
But, meanwhile like I'll sell you back
the hat you're wearing right now.
I will.
(laughing)
So I think it's important
to teach work ethic
because work ethic is the only thing
that maximizes what you naturally have.
And, it's really the best you can ask for.
- [Mark] What about sports?
What about sports with your children?
- I'm very into it.
I'm a little worried about
what the New York City
dynamic of sports is.
I didn't grow up--
- Sports are confusing
today it seems like.
You have to be a part of
something for so long.
- Yeah sports are tricky.
- It's a different commitment.
- Here's what I would say.
I'm gonna use sports a
little bit differently.
I'm obsessed with competition.
And, I really hope my
kids are competitive.
One, I'll say it again, I'm not interested
imposing any of my will on them.
If they're not competitive,
it'll be disappointing
'cause I love it for about four seconds,
and then I'll trick myself
into thinking it's great.
Like I'm just gonna go optimistic on it.
Sports is cool.
Team sports are cool.
I think it teaches people a lot of things.
- [Mark] The messages that
they might learn there--
- I mean listen I love sports.
I love sports.
My kids have shown interest
is sports this year
for the first time in a meaningful way.
My daughter especially which
is a lot of fun for me.
Yeah, again I'm very weird.
Like I really want to
reverse engineer my kids.
I wanna pay attention to their reactions,
figure out what's driving them,
and then quadruple down
on it, and then instill
the sprit of reality into it.
- [Mark] How do you pay attention to them
with so many different things going on?
- That's hard.
And, I would tell you that--
[Mark] Like sometimes
you're on your phone,
and you just fucking throw
it over your shoulder.
- I think my answer is I try.
First of all, I work too much.
So the limited time I have with them,
I try to stay focused.
But, like I'm selfish in my own stuff too.
I think it's important to be.
You know I think one of
the things I worry about
with a lot of stay at home parents.
And, obviously I don't know
what the percentage are,
but I think we still live in a world
where it's gotta be in
the 80s maybe even 90s
that the woman's staying at home.
I watch all these, you know
there's incredible women
that work for me, women entrepreneurs.
You know it's been interesting for me.
It feels like such a difficult game.
You know guys have it
so easy when children
come into the equation.
I feel like there's an enormous amount,
you know the balance of guilt, of keeping
your own identity, of
so many of these women.
We're living in a great age
where it's not the archaic
ages anymore.
There's a lot of women that
have unbelievable ambitions,
the greatest ambitions equal
to the ambitions of men
which they didn't have
50, 60, 30, 90 years ago.
And, so like that transition
seems very difficult.
And, I think when you lose
yourself in your children,
you lose.
You lose which then
means your children lose.
One of the things that I'm
very, very obsessed with is
I can't believe how many parents wrap
their own self-esteem into their
children's accomplishments.
- [Mark] That's wild isn't it?
- So this has been the
big eye opener for me.
This was probably the one thing I didn't,
I think I anticipated quite
a bit about parenting.
I think I nailed it.
I'm good at predicting shit.
(laughing)
Here's where I missed by a mile.
Like literally it struck
me at a parent event.
I was like wait a minute, wait a minute,
you actually feel better about yourself
'cause your kid can play chess.
You, not you love your
kid and you're happy
for your kid.
No, you think you're better
'cause you're the parent
of the chess player.
- [Mark] You think you're a bad ass.
- It blew me away.
My parents never wrapped
their self-esteem in me.
I wrap my self-esteem in only
myself not even my parents.
I'm very empathetic which
is why I'm a good salesman
and why I'm successful.
That's my gift, gratitude and empathy.
I wasn't empathetic to that
'casue I haven't lived it.
I never tasted it.
I never understood it.
And, then it opened up everything.
Like that's why people put bumper stickers
of like Harvard.
I'm like, oh shit, that's why parents
force their kids into collecting debt
to go to a university that
makes the parent feel good
verus the kid going to a secondary school
or a community college where they don't.
It unlocked a whole world
of like fuck you parents.
(laughing)
- I saw that in Little
League with my older son.
Two of the assistant coaches for his team,
they would have to call the sheriff
to calm them down because
if there was a call
at home plate that they
didn't like or a strike,
or whatever--
- That I actually agree with.
I want a fight.
I get sports.
That to me could be a nuance of that.
That could be true if Rick wants to fight
because he thinks he's little Timmy,
and he's a great baseball player.
I would just fight because I just want
my kid's team to win the game.
Yeah I just want to win the game.
- [Mark] It does get pretty heated.
- To me, those things actually
don't really freak me out
as much as the politically
correct world gets freaked out.
I just don't think it makes
any sense in the world.
You're a parent.
You're number one thing in the world
is to do everything right by that child.
Like they're at your mercy.
They're your kid.
And, parents are misfiring.
They're selfish.
- You ever heard this quote before?
The best way to have
an impact on the world
is to go home and love your family,
you ever heard that before.
It's by Mother Teresa.
- [Garyvee] Is that right?
- I think it's great.
It makes a lot of sense to me
because I'm trying to impact,
you know lifters like this.
I'm trying to impact trainers and people
in the fitness industry.
And, I'm super excited about it.
Then I'm at home, and I'm in my phone.
- I get it man.
- [Mark] And, my little girl's saying,
"Daddy, daddy, daddy?"
And, I'm like why am I doing this?
- I get it, and I think that's right.
I think it comes down to
your circumstance too.
So I'm the son of a first
generation immigrant
who worked every minute,
left before I woke up,
came home after I slept, slept in the home
that I slept in every single
night, took zero travel days.
So was in the same home, my dad slept.
This is not a divorce, this
is not a traveling father
like I am.
This is my father slept in the same home
that I slept in my entire life,
I just want everybody to hear this
'cause this is insane
actually in hindsight,
From the day I was born
to the day I left school,
like all of that.
Like old school, like just
came home every night.
I don't know what else to tell you.
And, I never saw him once.
And, when I tell you I never saw him once,
I spent more time with my kids
this Presidents' Day weekend
than my dad did with me my
entire childhood combined.
I don't think people--
[Mark] Was there ever a
term of being resentful?
- Didn't even cross my mind.
- [Jim] What was your impression of it?
- Thank God dad works so hard.
We came from nothing,
now we have a townhouse.
That's what it was.
It was gratitude.
It was optimism.
And, there wasn't a need.
My mom was so incredible.
And, again every kid's different.
I didn't need my dad.
Did I notice that a lot of people's dads
were at the Little League games?
Absolutely.
My dad went to one Little League game
my entire career, and I was pumped.
And, I did good.
It was an all star game.
I played well.
But, again I was a kid
that didn't need it.
I didn't need my dad.
I definitely needed my mom.
You need something, but
like I didn't need anything.
I've never been somebody
who validates himself
on anything on the outside.
And, that is a gift.
And, I think that goes back.
You have one?
- [Mark] I have two kids.
- Two.
Look they're gonna be different.
They're different.
Like Misha, my daughter, reminds me of me
because she never gave a shit
that I would leave the house.
"Bye dad."
"Misha, I'm gonna be gone for four days.
"I'll be back."
"Bye, dad."
My little guy's like not.
And, I'm like oh fuck I didn't realize
how good I had it with Misha.
Like this actually hurts my feelings.
I'm emotional.
This is sad.
And, you'll adjust.
The other thing is I just
said to Tyler, my admin,
like, and this is where
I was going with this,
this if very long winded to the thing,
how old are your kids?
- [Woman] 13 and nine.
- Right so you guys are
really in this zone,
you know how you said
the vegetables thing,
I'm very against that.
- [Mark] I'm against vegetables too.
(laughing)
Let's make a fucking stand together.
- Here's a huge irony.
You know this.
I love vegetables.
I'm against the cliche thing.
So one of the biggest
conversations I'm having
with my wife right now
is like, "Look Lizzie,
"I got to Oslo, Hong Kong, Melbourne.
"I'm going on all these amazing trips.
"I know that you're a little
bit more by the book,"
that's my wife, "Like
I need you to be open
"to what I wanna do which
is Misha's gonna miss
"13 days of school a
year that make no sense."
And, that's because I'm
gonna take her to Oslo.
And, she's gonna see what daddy does,
and we're gonna spend
six hours, eight hours
on the plan together.
We'll change, and you change.
When I sleep in one place twice,
we slept in Belgium
two nights, it's weird.
I stay nowhere more
than one night, nowhere.
Trips are to Europe and Asia.
These are eight hour
trips, nine hour trips,
13 hour trips.
They are insane.
- [Ryan] We didn't even
stay a night in Ireland.
We left.
- Right, I went to Dublin,
never even slept there.
Went from New York overnight to Dublin.
Dublin, speech, get on
a plane go to Belgium.
That's why we had two nights in Belgium.
- [Woman] Like a rockstar.
- But, now we'll adjust.
You know you get to adjust.
You get to be a parent forever.
All these parents want to
win in the first inning.
There's more to it.
Now I do think the early
years are foundational.
I don't disrespect them.
I do think feelings get
formulated at six, nine, 12,
14, 19 that may be harder.
But, let's be honest.
I need people to understand.
I'm gonna paint the picture
that everybody knows
is true and should really make all parents
feel better about themselves
and not make them crippled.
How many times do you need to see a child
reunited with a parent
that did everything wrong,
walked out on them, didn't
give a crap about them,
cheated on their spouse, stole the money,
alcoholic, drugs, it takes the kid
all but five minutes to
get one or two things
off their chest, and
they're back into the need
to rebuild that relationship.
These are our children.
- [Jim] It's baked in.
- It's so baked in, my man.
And, modern nitpicking
and political correctness
is trying to scare us into thinking
we're fucking this up.
- [Jim] Which is how we
get helicopter parents
because they're so afraid they're--
- And, these kids are losers.
So look do I wish I spend
more time with my kids?
Of course.
Do I think that things that I'm doing
will impact my kids in a positive way?
Absolutely, I genuinely do.
- [Jim] Well supply and
demand, the scarcity.
They appreciate the time you have.
- Yeah, right.
And, I don't wanna win on
that, but you're not wrong.
And, I don't want them to
take their mother for granted
because she deserves so much.
I'd be more reactionary
to that, because of that,
because I think she deserves that.
I hate when people get taken for granted.
I live my life getting taken for granted
'cause of the way I roll.
So I'm very anti that,
so I won't be a hypocrite
and do that to my wife.
You know then I break every rule
because, I wanna like,
you know it's so amazing.
It's so hard coming from nothing.
I don't wanna give them anything,
and I wanna give them everything.
And, I think we all go through.
Listen there's nothing I've said
every parent isn't, they're
shaking their head about
because we're all living it.
Here's the thing I am
saying that's different.
You're doing way better than you think.
I'm just tired of this, like first of all,
I don't give a shit about
what your opinion is
on how I'm parenting.
They're my kids, fuck face.
(laughing)
And, more importantly
my mom was snickered at
her whole life because
they never went anywhere.
There were no family vacations.
She parented me, and all the
Brooklyn Russian families
they'd go the second
they made a few bucks.
They went on every
cruise, and this and that.
And, now at every Russian wedding,
my parents are put on a
throne because of the way
their three kids ended up by comparison.
And, so to that point,
why I told that story
is one to give my parent credits.
And, two, this plays out.
You can have opinions
about how I'm parenting.
Let's see how it plays out.
- [Jim] It's a long game.
- Let's see who has better kids.
Let's see which kids
are winners and happy.
And, winning comes in different forms.
I know miserable billionaires.
I know a kid right now who grew up
with nothing but money,
he's successful right now,
and what does he do every night?
He does coke every night
that's what he does.
And, he's gonna lose.
- [Mark] That's not gonna play out well.
- And, everybody because of his Instagram
thinks he's winning.
You think he's winning.
He lost.
Meanwhile I have friends
that I grew up with,
great parenting, still live in
Hunterdon County, New Jersey.
Like going to the Mall is the legit thing,
and they've won.
So it's not just winning.
- [Mark] I can also buy a
boat, go fishing every weekend.
- My parents aren't happy
because of what I've
achieved.
Yes, because of what I've
achieved, but who I am.
- I think what you said earlier
about being selfish is really important.
That's something I preach a
lot of times at seminars too.
Is that you have to go
out there, and you have
to figure out a way to
take care of yourself.
- First.
- And, do the things that you love to do.
- First!
- So if you love doing this,
and you love being here
this is crucial.
And, you can't take care
of him, you can't take care
of him, and the 500 other people that work
inside of this building.
- 750.
(laughing)
And, first, I'm the engine.
If I break, everybody else is fucked.
Now for me, what really
got lucky was I'm built
like my mom which is
my fuel for that engine
is to make other people
happy which makes me popular
which makes me even more popular to people
that know me the best.
Which is really, by the
way, the way I judge myself.
The way I've basically been
judging myself through this
really interesting path
I'm living right now
is do the people that know me the best
like me the most.
- [Mark] Yeah like is he
pumped about going to Belgium
with you, or is like, "Fuck,
man, it's a paycheck, fuck?"
- Or, inevitably when he's
getting six or seven DMs a month
of like, "Is his shtick," like my stuff
comes off like a shtick
because I'm an anomaly.
I am over energized.
I am pumped.
I am more grateful.
I am louder.
I am more confident.
I am different.
I am, I'm different.
And, I like that.
- I got a legit message the other day
asking if you were a real human.
Someone legitimately messaged me and goes,
"Is he a real human?"
(laughing)
- You get that Todd?
- [Todd] I get those.
I've had people DM
asking if we plant people
that come up to you on the street.
- Oh that's a good one.
See to me that's just funny.
- Yeah that's hilarious.
- When I hear that, I would
think that if I planted
a human to take a selfie
with me to act cool
in a Daily Vee that that single move
would crumble my entire empire.
Because what, then I would have to make
all these people that actually know,
I'd have to keep them on the payroll.
I wanna fire these guys.
(laughing)
I'm being serious.
I have no interest in being held hostage.
The reason you need to live naked
is cause you don't want anybody
to have leverage over you.
I'm not letting anybody
have the upper hand on me.
He would have the upper hand
if I needed to make sure
that he told them, no, you know?
Fuck that.
And, you can't hold those
plates eventually one falls,
and it's over.
So one of the reasons I
live that kind of life
is leverage.
- How's your wife been?
Has she been a part of
a lot of the success
of what you've built up?
- She's the foundation of my success.
She's the enabler of my success.
If my wife wasn't so
selfless, I wouldn't be
what I am today.
And, you know what as a young man,
I didn't understand that.
- It seemed like you were so driven.
It seemed like you were
kind of born that was
just go full blast.
- And, at like 16, as I grew up,
my mom was teaching me to be a good man,
we'd have these conversations.
And, I'm like, "Mom, you
didn't build the liquor store.
"Dad built the liquor store.
"What the hell are you taking credit for?"
- Why are you saying we and us?
- And, of course, you
know what you realize
is when you start tasting life, is
I spend zero minutes worrying
about what Lizzie's thinking
anytime always which allows
me to do 100% my thing
which is a gift and a curse.
One, it's such a blessing to have
someone like that be your support system.
Second, it's daunting because
I'm just always petrified
to take it for granted.
She does what I do.
I think we love each other
so much because we're similar
in our real cores, and
we love ourselves so much
that I think it makes us
appreciate the other one.
Yeah, she's a big deal
- [Jim] Can you talk
about the business to her,
and she gets it or just no?
- No, and by the way, I could.
And, she's more than capable.
She's got it like that.
I don't want to.
I actually don't talk
about the business at all.
Like I keep it, you know, it's
funny to have Jordan here.
I spend as much time with
Jordan as I do with my wife.
I see him everyday for an hour.
I don't complain.
I don't talk about stuff.
Once in a blue moon,
the things I've told him
have been more predicated
on trying to teach him
how to be a business man
than the need to get it out.
- [Jim] You're trying to teach.
- I like teaching.
- [Jim] You're trying
to share what you know.
- I like it.
I'm a great teammate, coach.
I'm a great leader.
I just know it.
I'm a great leader 'cause
I care more about them
more than I care about
myself which that makes
them care enough about me that is matters.
It's fun to have Tyler here.
Tyler literally came here
to work for me for a year,
learn, I guess, I mean
I'm speaking for you,
get the brand association,
get the exposure.
- [Mark] Steal from you and leave.
- You know what I would call it,
get return value.
And, there are people
who want to do that part,
and by the way, the best part
is I'm fine with that too
'cause I'm on to the
next thing, the next day.
But, very quickly, and
we had this conversation.
Actually, how quickly did you realize
maybe I shouldn't just stay for a year,
maybe I should play this
out a little bit longer?
- [Tyler] Pretty quickly.
- Like how quickly?
Like seriously, don't bullshit me.
- [Tyler] Within like
the first month or two
of being on the team.
- That's it.
That's great leadership.
Young man comes in with a plan for his own
and realizes wait a minute
there's so much good here
for me, he's not doing
that cause he's been
tricked by me.
He's doing it because he thinks
it's in his best interest.
- [Jim] To be part of something bigger.
- Mike who was my last
trainer before Jordan.
Like the last couple
months, I could tell you.
He's like, "Maybe I shouldn't leave."
- He made YouTube videos.
He's like, "I'm really second
guessing this decision.
(laughing)
- I've already been like I'm
probably gonna stay longer.
I feel like he's gonna push
boxing back a little bit.
- I want to do boxing next.
- I heard kind of I'm
actually gonna box on Fridays.
I box with the kid, and
one of our neighbors.
He used to box.
And, so I said, "Dude,
you gotta shake my hand
"right now and pick me up at six a.m.
"cause otherwise I won't fucking go,
"and we'll just talk about it."
I'm excited about that.
You know you talked kind
of recently about return
on investment, and you talked
about how that's everyone's
kind of first thought is
how do I get my money back.
How do I get my money back
on this Facebook post,
this Instagram post, and so on.
- That's right tactics over religion.
- Yeah I've heard you
talk about that before.
- So my gym is free, and
when I made my gym free
years ago, somebody said, "Why'd you make
"your gym free."
And, I said, "To become a millionaire."
And, my friend who's Dick Lickerson.
- [Jim] It's not his real name.
He's the intro voice of the podcast.
- Is he?
- He just kind of tapped
me on the shoulder
he's like, "I believe
in what you just said.
"I can see it in your eyes.
"I know what you're getting at."
- That's cool.
- And, so the whole reason
for making the gym free
was a bunch of reasons,
but reason number one
was to pay it back to power lifting.
I've gotten so much out of power lifting.
- Yeah that's cool.
- Having a team and
having people around me
kind of lifting and pushing me forward
that I felt amazing about it.
But, in your situation,
how do you get back
your return?
Maybe in a different way that's not money.
- Money.
- [Jim] It's still money.
- And, I'm making a joke.
I think that people are not smart.
And, let me tell you what I mean by that.
I am so confused by people's
inability to understand
what's happening.
Everything is predicated on action.
Like it's just actions.
I don't listen to what anybody says
I just pay attention to what they do.
So for me, I have very big ambitions,
but one thing that I don't
think, I'm blown away
by people not remembering
that for 13 years of my life
out of school, I didn't build a brand.
I wasn't speaking.
I wasn't Garyvee.
My name was Gary Vaynerchuk, and I worked
at a liquor store every single day,
and I built an eCommerce business
and built fulfillment.
These are things I don't talk about.
I invented fulfillment.
I didn't know it.
I didn't go to school for fulfillment.
I invented fulfillment for myself.
- [Mark] You made being
an entrepreneur cool
which before meant you didn't have a job.
- And, I don't think I did it.
I think I've been a small piece of it.
I will tell you I think that
it was the Facebook movie
that made it cool.
I think it's the extreme
wealth at such a young age.
Billionaires were 60 and
old and no 18 year old
could associate with that.
When they were like, "Wait a minute
"that dude's a billionaire,
and he's wearing
"a hoodie and sneakers, and he's 27."
That changed everything.
I think I rode the wave the was created
moreso than helped.
Now the good thing is it was my truth
unlike everybody else
who was like meant to be
a trainer, but now says
they're an entrepreneur
and a trainer 'cause it's cool,
or they want to sell swag on Instagram.
You see where I'm going?
What's been fun for me is it's my truth.
Like that's fun.
This isn't a fly by night thing.
This was my truth.
So I think, to answer your question,
it's not the money.
Anybody that's really smart would know
I knew how to make money
before I became me.
I made money before I became me.
When I invested in Twitter
and Tumblr and Uber,
that was before I became
who everybody knows me as.
I don't need to monetize my audience.
You know I'll take this opportunity,
make sure you use it.
I don't begrudge people that
monetize their audience.
I'm just reminding them that I don't.
It's an important conversation.
And, somebody will jump in and say,
"Well yeah Gary, what about
your books, and your t-shirts?"
And, then I would say
again, "You are not smart."
Because if you understood
the economics behind that
in comparison to what I
do, I will make more money
giving one speech than I
will in everything I do
in t-shirts this entire year.
Don't you think it's be
smarter for me to do that?
I do it because it's fun.
I like somebody wearing a
t-shirt with my quote on it
'cause I am vain, and I like it.
I like giving them out.
I noticed, like again,
people are not smart.
When I started the 60 second club,
and it's working for me on Instagram.
I'm giving away my books.
A lot of people have the books.
So if I create t-shirts,
it's something for me
to give back which creates
even more of a relationship.
And, by the way, I want
to remind everybody.
I am by hand, not somebody
here, you know this,
you know this.
I, me, me, by hand going into my comments,
reading it, replying that
they've won, tagging them,
screen shooting it, drawing.
You know what I mean, I'm doing it.
So my answer is very simple.
I want to leave a legacy.
I want to be the greatest,
most admired entrepreneur
of all time, and I want
to do it by not amassing
the most wealth.
I want to do it by
amassing the most wealth
and give back to the community in parallel
because I'm leaving enormous amounts
of money on the table
by doing what I'm doing
in content.
Do people not remember all
these people cost me money.
(laughing)
He costs me more money, than all the money
I'll make on t-shirts this year.
It's not good trade.
- [Mark] Son of a bitch.
You're charging a lot back there.
- You know they don't get it.
And, by the way, I'm not mad
because 99% of the people
are not good enough business people to go
through the whole process in their brain.
So I'm not mad.
I just disagree with people's opinion,
and I laugh at their comments.
And, I enjoy the negative
comments in social
because it drives me and reminds me
that, one, I need to
respect and be grounded
at all times, and two, that
I'm just dramatically smarter
than a lot of people.
- [Mark] So we got you deadlifting.
We got you into some fitness.
How do we get you on a cycle of steroids?
- This is a funny conversation.
This is vegetables to me.
And, I brought this up to you.
I don't think I'm gonna
do it because I think
I'm too grounded in it's vegetables.
But, and I'm not educated.
But, I can tell you right
now I'm very fascinated
from the couple, so the
reason why I don't want
to speak about this is less about me
not wanting to do steroids as I don't want
to be a hypocrite.
I make fun of, and you know
this, headline readers.
I know what's going on in
Facebook, and Snapchat,
and Instagram.
I know the headlines are maybe steroids
isn't as bad as you necessarily think.
Maybe after a certain
age, at 16 it's scarier
than maybe if you're 45.
I'm actually weirdly fascinated by it.
But, I also know I'm a headline reader.
It's a couple of conversations with Mike.
It's a couple conversations with him.
It's a couple of tweets I've seen.
It's a couple of things I've heard.
But, you know like to me, smoking was fine
for you in 1947.
(laughing)
I'll tell you right
now I'm way more scared
about putting a cell phone to my head
and getting brain cancer than steroids.
So I think people are not smart.
And, so I will tell you if
I had to make a prediction,
I would tell you it's
not out of the question
for me to do a cycle.
I'm being serious.
- [Mark] I'm gonna come back here
you'll be just jacked out of your mind.
(laughing)
- It's not out of the question.
Now I am a little bit of a
purist, AKA, I'm still enjoying.
How long have you been working out?
- [Mark] Shit, since I was 12, and I'm 40.
So a long time.
- Good, so you've seen it.
Like this is the first time in my life
that I'm actually seeing something happen
out of the work you put it.
- [Mark] That's awesome.
- Right.
The same reason I'm doing
all my own social media
is the same reason I would
probably not do steroids
because of that cause I like doing it,
moreso than me thinking
it's bad or what, got it?
- [Mark] That makes sense.
- [Jim] So if there were
steroids that helped people
in business, what things
would it improve about them?
- Emotional intelligence,
empathy, gratitude,
self awareness.
Businesses break because
human beings break them.
Companies don't get bigger
because all these assholes
want to micromanage everything
'cause it makes them
feel better.
- [Mark] If you spread
all the world's wealth,
they've said before, if you
spread all the world's wealth
around to everybody
equally, it would end up
in the pockets of the rich in
a very short period of time.
- Of course.
Talent is talent.
Winners win.
Like that's just the game.
And, so the people that are
not in a path of winning,
need to do something drastically
to break their behavior
because that's why they're not winning.
Normally, it's association
of something in someone else.
One of the things that is
driving me more than ever
is for some reason my communication style
penetrates people that are
not normally penetrated
by communication styles.
And, to be very frank
with you, I'd feel guilty
if I didn't continue down that path
because it's helping people.
I don't know what else to say.
It's fucking awesome.
- [Mark] I think when I listen to you
what resonates with me is
it almost feels like I'm
listening to a podcast or
listening to a conversation,
I feel like I'm part of it.
I feel like I'm in the room as well.
And, we know from doing this podcast,
we've had a similar impact on people
where there's been
people that are listening
to it in their car, and
they've shouted stuff out
because they feel like we're really there.
- Well I'll tell you, and I'll
give you a nice complement.
I even feel it while you're doing this.
This feels much more like
we're actually hanging out
than I'm doing a podcast, genuinely.
- I'll take that complement.
- And, I do a lot of them, and
some people are good at it.
Maybe even the dynamic of two of you.
And, actually no question
cause I know myself,
having them three here, but I feel it.
Makes sense.
- I think part of it too is that people
listen to podcasts with earbuds.
- I'm obsessed with audio.
And again, watch me, don't
listen to what I said.
I haven't talked a lot about podcasting.
But, you know if you're consuming me,
I rebranded it from the Ask Gary Vee Show
to the Gary Vee Audio Experience.
I started pushing it very aggressively
in my social channels.
I created a podcast tab on my website.
I took it to all platforms,
Sound Cloud and Spotify.
If you really watch every
single piece of my content,
hired an audio guy cause
you've seen him in a couple
of shots.
I haven't gotten to tell
you about podcasting
or anybody about podcasting.
One, it's been covered very well.
I'm not a podcasting pioneer.
This has been around.
Ferris and Rogan and
Louis Herriman, Pat Flynn.
People've done it.
People have talked about
it, people understand it.
So that's why I keep saying
watch me, don't listen to me.
- [Mark] Makes Sense.
- Yeah I think so.
Back to, I brought it up earlier right?
I don't listen to what you're saying.
I love when people are like, everybody's,
"I'm a good person."
I have never tweeted a single
donation I've ever given.
I'm more than willing to bring
out my tax form right now.
- I always think that's weird.
- You think it's weird because
of how you're grounded.
You think it's weird for the same reason
I think it's weird because you can taste
the bullshit behind it.
- It doesn't taste very good.
- There's only one reason you like me
it's cause I'm the pure version of it.
- That's right.
- I know.
And, so the reason I don't do that is
I'm not tricked by somebody saying,
"Just donated to Haiti after the,"
they're doing it for their own selves.
- One of my favorite
things that you talk about
is not being fancy.
So if we can just end on a fancy rant,
- Let's do it.
- Then I would be more than satisfied.
- Okay good, you want me to expand on it?
- [Mark] Absolutely.
- I don't think when you make
your first fucking dollars
you need a fucking Lambo.
I don't understand that
people don't understand.
I love it.
And, listen again empathy.
You never had anything.
You just were broke.
I'd love to know a little more details.
I'm not mad if you want
to go buy a nice purse
or a nice watch.
- [Mark] Treat yourself.
- I think it's important.
By the way, let me talk about a flaw.
I actually think I'm very bad at that.
I don't celebrate shit.
You know like, fuck, this
is an actual conversation
between me and my brother.
- [Mark] I think that's
excellent in the sense
that it could potentially prevent
you from potentially being
an addict because you
would wanna celebrate
with alcohol or something.
- Interesting.
Right maybe.
But no, it's actually way
worse than that, my man.
It's actually like not
even acknowledging it.
It's actually quite scary.
- [Mark] Kyree Sanders,
scoring a touchdown,
flipping the ball to the ref.
- It's so funny.
I'm such a polar opposite.
It's so weird.
That's exactly what it is,
yet until you just said that,
I would've thought that
I would have been T.O.
if I was in football.
And, I do think my strength comes,
I often think that I'll
call my autobiography,
you know obviously I have
the honey empire thing now.
There's a big part of me that
thinks it'd be really funny
that I'd just called it He Did It
because when I buy the Jets.
(laughing)
But, I do think the purest
form of my autobiography,
like the purest title of my
life is gonna be The Bridge.
I think I pull so hard
from opposite directions.
- [Mark] It's that strong
man event, you ever see that
where they guy's holding--
- Actually, I'm gonna articulate it.
It's more for you than
it is for anything else.
At a macro, I'm the least fancy.
In a micro, I can be fancy.
Right?
Like in my micro, on stage.
It's almost like it's
the steak and the sizzle.
I got lots of sizzle,
but my fucking steak,
you know like that's it.
So fancy.
I generally for your audience.
I think that too many of you want stuff,
and it's the quickest
way to not have stuff.
- [Mark] I make products, and
anytime I've gotten fancy,
wham, it hits me right back in the face.
And, it doesn't fucking work.
And, I'm like, "Fuck I thought
this was such a good idea."
I had all these intentions.
And, I had all the best intentions.
I tried to fancy it
up, and it's fucked up.
- And, I think one of the biggest reasons
I'm upset with entrepreneurship
through Instagram.
Instagram entrepreneurs,
actually that's a good new term.
- [Mark] Hashtag.
- Instagram entrepreneurs upset me
because they only push
watches and hot chicks
and private planes.
And, to me, it's the process.
To me, you know when Jordan and I talk
about working out, and
when he's impressed with me
or happy with me, it just makes
so much sense to me because I am happy.
I don't need to dress
up and go to Equinox.
(laughing)
You guys all like that.
That was a good one?
- [Mark] We should do
that right now actually.
(laughing)
- I need to just put in the work.
Like, I like the grind.
I like the process.
You know what's funny?
And, he'll probably tell you this.
I like the steps back.
I kind of weirdly enjoy, I get mad
when I know I had a bad session.
And, I workout seven days a week.
Now we also like one day it's
like we're just rolling out.
- [Mark] Soft tissue shit?
- Yeah, but I'm there seven days a week.
And, some days don't make sense.
Like some days was like
the day before it was
a soft tissue day, and so
I should be super rested
and a solid day of sleep, and
somehow it just didn't click.
And, other days he'll go
back and actually answer
that person, he's not
human 'cause I just watched
him sleep three, four, and five hours
and have the three best workouts.
I don't even understand that.
And, he's 41.
So I like the ups and downs.
I love the journey, my man.
I love the journey of life.
I love the journey of business.
I love the journey I'm
going through with fitness.
I love the process.
You have to love the process.
If you love the process,
you've already won.
It's how you fix it.
The way you fix the game,
like the way you hedge it.
The way it's like you
fix it, like fixing it.
I've fixed my outcome.
I don't give a fuck if
I don't buy the Jets.
The ambition to, and the
journey to try to achieve it
is the game.
- [Mark] The Jets are so fucked.
(laughing)
I'm from Poughkeepsie, New York.
I've been a fan forever,
and they've been--
- It's been bad, bro.
- [Mark] They've been
so fucked for so long.
We gotta bring back fucking Ken O'Brien.
- Or Richard Todd.
I think the truth is like that
only fits my narrative more
because when the prodigal son comes home
and buys them and brings a championship.
I'll get to be the Lebron of the Jets.
- [Mark] Thank you so much for your time.
I appreciate it.
- Thank you so much.